Oi e aí galera que assiste meu canal bom
dia tomar já já tomei meu cafezinho
agora tem um suquinho verde para mais
o show instrumento acho que tu vem cá
vem vem aqui vem aqui
tem um outro vocês Olha que bonitinho de
dia aqui
e a Lalá o sol bonito tá quando você Bom
se você está acompanhando aí os nossos
vendas e os nossos vídeos vocês devem
ver que a gente tá fazendo show todo dia
inclusive hoje faz uma coisa
interessante que acontece eu recebo
muito presente de fã antigamente recebia
mais quando era mais jovem né da hora
mais justo aí você chegar no show com
uma van eu tinha que voltar com duas
mãos que uma hora só de urso e carta
hoje em dia eu e deve ser maiores o suas
com as pessoas também não quer mais
ficar escrevendo de dia se digita não se
escreve a dei que você nunca mais me deu
uma cartinha Avé Maria quer que eu faço
com a pena também não com a tinta vamos
voltar logo para 1825 ignorantes que Ave
Maria então não tá tudo bem ursinho Eu
tenho um quarto na minha cidade cheia de
urso hoje em dia esse quarto ele não é
mais alimentar tanto com você porque
meus pais cresceram né todo mundo tem
que comprar seus remédios para depressão
e participar do papo mesmo
menos eu conversei com essa internet era
jovem era adolescente a galera que tem
acompanhado também era todo mundo quer
ser juntos eu fico muito feliz a galera
me manda mensagem ou eu vou ter que
fechar o fã-clube porque e na faculdade
eu tenho que estudar e focar e eu fico
feliz foi evolução entendeu porque eu
fico feliz quando as pessoas ficam feliz
quando eu fico feliz tá brincamdo eu
com minha mudança porque eu mudo todos
os dias tem gente que fala assim não
muda não não mude nunca seja sempre essa
pessoa que você é mas isso não existe
que a gente muda toda hora tenho quando
a pessoa fica feliz e acompanha a minha
mudança Poxa eu acho massa demais por
isso que eu fico feliz e acompanha a
mudança dos meus pais também quando eu
tenho que fechar um fã-clube porque você
tem que focar no estudo da faculdade é
massa demais e uma das coisas que
aumentou muito com o tempo foi meus fã
talentoso mas tem muita gente que me dá
desenho presente coisa muito doida mas
já vi que fez eu no fogo uma vez com
fumaça de vela e teve esse cara que me
entregou esse desenho muito bonito e
muito carinhoso lá no camarim do show
Olha isso é
[Música]
E aí
e
no Brasil do Esporte
sobre
fazer as coisas acontecendo com você te
amo muito
obrigado obrigado mesmo vem das três
ações são Big
tipo muito feliz muito talentoso se você
tem algum talento comenta aqui embaixo
Qual é o talento que você tem não
importa se é jogar o negócio e outro
amigo a para na boca você é Golf você
teme se a desenhar você cantasse é se
você é um artesão comenta aqui embaixo
deixa eu ver deixa conhecer quem é
quem é o primo da Regina bacana não
esquece de clicar em gostei também esse
você forte de Fortaleza ou de algum dos
lugares que eu vou fazer show no próximo
mês na Europa e pode me entregar sua
arte Ai que gostoso Não esquece assistir
os vídeos anteriores em tem muitos
outros lá e também vai ter dependendo do
número que tem aqui são 30 31 se tiver
tipo sei lá 6 8 12 por que tem mais para
frente mas para trás Tá bom
então dá um aquela aqui para o pessoal
te ver quem é você mano Eu queria também
dizer que se você está no Twitter vendo
isso aqui ai meu Deus Deus te amo papai
desculpa eu também queria dizer Opa por
favor também queria falar que você tá no
Twitter não esquece de dar RT nesse
tweet em que divulga o vídeo tá vamos
criar a comunidade do Twitter que
participa sempre da galera do vendo aqui
que eu sei que não é todo mundo que quer
assistir vídeo Todo dia eu sei que não é
todo mundo que quer ficar vendo um jogar
ó tá vendo o cara sabe fazer uma coisa
normal teve a do dia a dia mas eu sei
que tem muita gente que como eu é muito
interessado em saber como é que a vida
das pessoas quando não está sendo
filmado eu mostro pouco eu como eu tô
mostrando muito eu sei que interessante
algumas pessoas vão criar essa
comunidade é sempre volte lá no meu
Twitter onde eu postei e de RT vamos
ficar aumentando aumentando aumentando
aumentando aumentando que logo mais vou
começar a fazer umas promoções lá para
trazer gente para passar o dia inteiro
aqui com a gente vai trazer gente para
treinar comigo para trazer a gente para
desenhar para fazer coisa que eu quero
trazer um monte de gente criativa pode
dar com a gente da tropinha do Hype Tá
bom não esquece de clicar em gostei e
bota lá no Twitter de RT e comentar Qual
é o seu talento aqui embaixo tamo junto
e é nós
tchau tchau tchau tchau